en este vídeo lo que quiero hacer es
hablar acerca de un concepto que hemos
mencionado brevemente en vídeos
anteriores pero ahora de una manera un
poco más precisa vamos a hablar acerca
de la utilidad utilidad sale la utilidad
pues como ya hemos mencionado un poquito
tiene que ver con una cierta
satisfacción o un cierto valor lo voy a
poner aquí satisfacción satisfacción a
un cierto valor satisfacción o cierto
valor que obtenemos al adquirir un bien
o un servicio sin embargo ahorita no
vamos a medirlo como antes
antes cuando hablábamos por ejemplo de
obtener un honda civic adicional
hablamos del beneficio en términos de
pesos o vaya en términos monetarios y
pues hablamos de una cosa que se llamaba
beneficio marginal que tenía que ver con
obtener algo adicional y pues por
ejemplo también platicamos de esto
cuando cuando hablamos de la frontera de
posibilidades de producción por ejemplo
hablábamos del beneficio marginal de
obtener un conejo pero en términos de
bayas verdad de obtener un conejo
adicional entonces lo poníamos en
términos de otro bien o servicio ahorita
no lo que vamos a hacer es pensar en
términos absolutos
y lo que vamos a hacer es trabajar con
un ejemplo de chocolate y fruta y aquí
vamos a asignar unas ciertas unidades de
utilidad marginal que van a ser unidades
abstractas no van a ser ni pesos ni
otros bienes ni servicios entonces con
eso vamos a prestar a pensar de una
manera absoluta y después vamos a ver
cómo se relaciona esto de aquí con la
demanda de ciertos bienes y servicios y
con su precio entonces pues no vamos a
ver cualquier tipo de utilidad sino la
utilidad marginal déjame le escribo por
aquí utilidad
utilidad marginal marginal y la
distinción de marginal tiene que ver con
que no es la utilidad total o sea no
estamos pensando en toda la utilidad
obtenida por adquirir muchos bienes sino
en la utilidad que obtenemos por obtener
bienes adicionales y osea ya que tenemos
unos cuál es la utilidad que obtenemos
por uno más y hay otra otra cosa que
quiero aclarar que es utilidad marginal
contra beneficio marginal porque estas
de aquí son palabras muy parecidas
verdad beneficio marginal
y marginal de hecho hasta se podría
definir utilidad en términos de
beneficio entonces uno podría
preguntarse cuál es la diferencia y en
realidad así la respuesta corta es que
conceptualmente no hay ninguna
diferencia sin embargo usualmente cuando
se habla de beneficio marginal se habla
en términos de pues en términos
monetarios en términos de otro bien y
cuando se habla de una utilidad marginal
se habla más como en términos absolutos
o sea en ciertas unidades de utilidad
que no dependen por el momento de ningún
otro bien o de ningún término de ninguna
moneda vale bueno entonces lo que vamos
a hacer es utilizar unas unidades
absolutas después vamos a poner precios
y vamos a llegar a algunas conclusiones
acerca de la canasta básica y de cómo se
compra y cómo se vende entonces pasamos
a este ejemplo de por acá abajo que son
tabletas para el chocolate y fruta
entonces de este lado tenemos la
cantidad de piezas que se obtienen bueno
aquí son barras barras de chocolate aquí
son kilos de fruta y del lado derecho
tenemos la utilidad marginal vale
entonces por ejemplo que nos dice esto
nos dice que si pues tenemos 0
chocolates
queremos adquirir uno eso nos va a dar
un beneficio o una utilidad de 100 100
que pues 100 unidades de utilidad
ahorita no nos importa que son pero si
ya tenemos un chocolate y queremos pasar
al segundo entonces nada más obtendremos
80 unidades entonces por ejemplo aquí
dice que pues comparado la primera barra
de chocolate contra el primer kilo de
fruta entonces preferimos 20% más el
primer kilo de fruta que la primera
barra de chocolate en realidad esto de
acá nada más es como pues como
proporcional si en realidad podría
quitarle todos los ceros acá les podría
hacer 10 8 6 y 4
aquí 12 10 5 y 20 lo importante es que
relativamente reflejen las preferencias
de la persona que va a comprar vale
bueno entonces mira acá la izquierda un
chocolate nos da una utilidad marginal
de 100 dos chocolates pues si ya tenemos
un chocolate entonces ya no tenemos
tantísimas ganas de chocolate verdad a
lo mejor ya nos en chocolate amos un
poquito ya nada más nos da un este
beneficio o una utilidad de 80 luego el
tercer chocolate nada más una utilidad
de 60 porque ya estamos harto
de chocolate el cuarto chocolate nos da
una utilidad más baja y podríamos
continuar esta tabla a lo mejor si ya
tengo 15 chocolates y me van a dar una
adicional en realidad yo no lo quiero o
sea más bien hasta podría tener una
utilidad marginal negativa si yo pagaría
por porque se lo llevaran o algo así
bueno de modo similar aquí pues el
primer kilo de fruta me entusiasma
muchísimo me da muchísima utilidad de
hecho me da 20% más de utilidad que el
primer que la primera barra de chocolate
pero luego el segundo kilo ya no me
emociona tanto el tercer kilo ya no me
emociona tanto y así sucesivamente ojo
recuerda que esto es utilidad marginal y
no es utilidad total aquí es el primer
chocolate aquí es el segundo chocolate
que todavía disfruto pero ya no lo
disfruto tanto como el primero si quiero
la utilidad total tendría que sumar
estos dos y entonces la utilidad total
de dos chocolates sería de 220 unidades
de utilidad vale bueno esta información
de aquí está buena verdad o sea nos da
cosas acerca de las preferencias nos
dice esto de que pues preferimos 20% más
la el primer kilo de fruta que la
primera barra de chocolate
que perseveremos 20% más el primer kilo
de fruta que el segundo kilo de fruta o
20% más del primer chocolate que el
chocolate y así pero todavía no nos dice
cómo podemos gastar nuestro dinero si
osea así nada más con esta información
no sabemos si queremos comprar pues la
primera barra de chocolate o el primer
kilo de fruta como sabemos si queremos
comprar este western pues todavía nos
falta un poco de información nos falta
saber cuánto cuesta cada barra de
chocolate y cuánto cuesta cada kilo de
fruta entonces lo que vamos a hacer
ahorita es ponerle precios a esto de acá
vale entonces supongamos que cada barra
de chocolate cuesta 10 pesos me voy a
poner aquí que cuesta 10 pesos se venden
10 pesos y que cada kilo de frutas se
vende vamos a poner que se vende en 20
pesos vale
a 20 pesos entonces aquí vamos a
calcular otro numerito que ya no es
utilidad marginal sino utilidad marginal
por precio déjame escribirla aquí
arribita que lo que queremos ahora
calcular en esta columna es utilidad
marginal del chocolate entre el precio
del chocolate entonces aquí vamos a
obtener un nuevo número lo voy a poner
con este color rosa rosa mexicano
entonces como cómo funciona esto pues ve
aquí tenemos 100 unidades de utilidad
pero están repartidas en 10 pesos porque
cada barra cada barra cuesta 10 pesos
entonces tendríamos que dividir entre 10
para calcular este numerito de acá
cuánta utilidad obtenemos por cada peso
que estamos gastando entonces aquí sería
100 entre 10 aquí sería 10 y sería 80
entre 10 sería 8 está un poco aburrido
verdad nada más es quitar los ceros
sería 6
aquí sería 4 y ahora pasemos del lado
derecho de modo similar ahora lo que
queremos calcular es la utilidad
marginal de la fruta pero por el precio
de la fruta es decir por cada peso que
estoy gastando en fruta qué tanta
utilidad estoy obteniendo aquí las
cuentas quedan un poco un poco más
difíciles verdad otra vez hay que
cancelar un cero pero luego nada más hay
que dividir entre dos por ejemplo aquí
tendría 120 entre 20 120 entre 20 se
cancela el 0 12 entre 2 es igual a 6
aunque entonces cancelamos el 0 y
dividimos entre 2 aquí es 12 12 entre
los 16 aquí es 10 entre 12 5 luego aquí
es 5 entre 2 es 2.5 y aquí sería 1
muy bien entonces ahora sí ya tenemos
unos números que nos permiten determinar
cómo gastar de cierta cantidad de dinero
por ejemplo no sé supongamos que tenemos
voy a escribirle acá arriba que tenemos
50 pesos para gastar entonces tenemos 50
pesos para gastar y los vamos a gastar
de 10 en 10 vale entonces vamos a pensar
cómo van a estar distribuidos esos esos
10 pesos y es pesos 10 pesos y 10 pesos
lo voy a poner acá aquí tenemos 10 pesos
luego tenemos otros 10 pesos otros 10
pesos
10 pesos y 10 pesos y bueno uno como
persona que le gusta disfrutar de la
vida pues tiene que ver pues que le
conviene comprar más y en estos primeros
diez pesos se pueden utilizar en comprar
pues ya sea esto de acá que puede ser
éste
o sea una barra de chocolate que nos da
10 de beneficio o se pueden utilizar en
comprar esto de acá que sería este pues
medio kilo de fruta verdad en el primer
kilo de fruta pues te como cueste 20
pesos con 10 pesos o lo podemos comprar
la mitad entonces como acá la utilidad
marginal por precio es de 6 y acá es de
10 pues vamos a quedarnos con el primer
chocolate entonces este de acá sería
chocolate le voy a poner así chocolate
chocolate luego vamos con los otros 10
pesos ahorita ya este de acá ya ya ya
compramos la primera barra de chocolate
ahora qué nos conviene pues todavía
chocolate verde chocolate nos sigue
dando este más utilidad por nuestro
dinero aquí son 8 y aquí son 6 entonces
otra vez nos compramos un chocolate
entonces el segundo también el chocolate
vamos con con la esfera el tercer
cachito de 10 pesos con el tercer
cachito de 10 pesos podríamos comprar el
tercer chocolate que nos da una utilidad
este por precio de 6 o también podríamos
comprar acá el kilo verdad bueno medio
kilo que nos da otra vez una utilidad
imaginar por precio de 6 entonces nos da
lo mismo supongamos que compramos el
chocolate en realidad podríamos lanzar
una moneda y decidir a partir de eso
pero le voy a poner que el chocolate sin
embargo qué sucede ahorita aquí en el
cuarto chocolate ya nada más obtenemos
una utilidad marginal por precio de 4
pero si empezamos a comprar fruta por
kilos o por medios kilos porque son 10
pesos y el kilo cuesta 20 obtenemos una
utilidad marginal por precio de 6
entonces aquí ya no vamos a compra
el chocolate porque ahora aquí obtenemos
mayor utilidad entonces en esta ocasión
compraríamos medio kilo de fruta
entonces ahí llevamos medio kilo todavía
podemos gastar otro medio kilo verdad si
sin cambiar de utilidad entonces aquí le
vamos a poner fruta y entonces podemos
pensar que estos dos últimos 10 pesos o
bueno estos 20 pesos se utilizaron en
comprar un un kilo de fruta bueno
entonces ésta de ahí es la idea es útil
empezar así con unas unidades de
utilidad marginal como que medio
abstractas porque nos dicen que tanto
nos satisface un bien sobre otro bien
según las cantidades que adquirimos pero
luego cuando le ponemos precios
podemos pensar racionalmente en cómo
gastar el dinero en este caso lo que
concluimos es que lo mejor es comprar
tres chocolates y un kilo de frutas